hi looking back to Sarah's music today
we're in santa barbara in southern
california and we'll be spending the
whole day surrounded by music at the
beautiful music academy of the West
since the early 1950s young musicians
from all over the world has come here to
Music Academy of the West to study music
intensively for eight weeks in these
beautiful and supportive surroundings
you
we don't want we want to hear
Scott thank you so much for having us
here today it is a stunning place oh
such such a pleasure you brought a
beautiful buzz and energy to this campus
today tell me something I've noticed on
campus it's not only that it's about
music I've noticed how supportive this
whole environment is the the fellows
they can do their thing they can
practice but you also support them in a
fantastic way you have great things on
offer for them not just music don't you
well that's the idea I mean a
professional musician it's what they do
on stage but it's a lifestyle it's it's
a complete a skill that they have to
have both onstage and offstage because
the idea is what kind of healthy tools
that can they have off stage that are
going to be able to sustain their career
on stage I mean you know firsthand how
absolutely important that is and so we
do try to provide them those tools
throughout the summer you know we're
representing 10 different countries in
20 different states with our fellow so
they get to come and really experience
the West Coast lifestyle which really is
health body and spirit it really is yeah
and you also have a performance coach
and it just tell me a little bit more
what's on offer for all the fellows so
we do we have a performance psychologist
he comes and he works with the fellows
on performance anxiety how to have a
really good performance but then not
have a really low performance but really
find something that that can always be a
good performance over and over again so
giving them tools to really be able to
perform at their best all the time and I
think that that's what is is one of the
really distinct factors about our
program is providing opportunities for
the bellows to have a healthy happy
career in music which is a lifestyle it
also has a very personal touch here
because you have your comp ears and your
patrons and they that the comp ears look
after your fellows but I have the
feeling you look exactly it who should
be paired with who we do it's it's kind
of like a match com type of scenario we
have the fellow sending information
about themselves of course we know our
our donor base very well but we actually
asked them to send an information as
well and so we have a committee and over
a two-week period
what they do is they try to make the
best match as possible and so when the
bellows get here and they like Italian
food and they want to practice their
French and they like you know horseback
riding we've got a comp here that has
that same kind of profile and something
that I wish I had that when I I was
studying it something that one didn't
really talk about much in the old days
you just got into a practice room
practiced did an audition got the job
but this whole lifestyle idea is
something very special to you guys I
think well and one of the things that's
so important which I hope you've seen is
the engagement of our community and what
we say here is that we really try to
give our fellows the opportunity to
practice their artistry which is kind of
an interesting concept but just like
you're saying to get out of the practice
room you can practice you can practice
your technique in that little box that
we know all musicians get to know very
well in their careers but actually
getting on stage performing learning how
to communicate and that takes a full
audience so what we try to do is in one
of the most important things is when a
fellow walks out on stage they have a
full audience every seat bowl or as many
as possible full so they can get out
there they can perform over and over
again in front of a live audience and
practice communication and we find so
many times artists don't get that
opportunity Matt what a fantastic place
to spend the summer it is it really is
you're the really one of the shooting
stars of the American composer
conducting scene but you are the same
age as most of the fellows and so tell
me what you're doing with them and how
is that being the same age well we're
doing a chamber opera that I wrote
called second nature and then we're
performing as madness' the bartered
bride there's no better way for a
composer to inspire um sympathy or a
feeling of being co-conspirators then
actually performing the music yourself
you know if you say I'm willing to
suffer with you maybe it's terrible but
at least I'm in the I'm in the fire and
with you i think the musicians enjoy
that
and now from the beach what else the
water music
careers have been inspired at the Music
Academy of the West one of the most
famous being the legendary singer
Marilyn Florence
this one thank you so much for coming to
talk to us today in this amazing campus
you've spent more summers here than most
yes I have and in fact my first summer
was in 1953 when I was 19 as a student
here and I was studying with some of the
greatest teachers of all time headed up
of course by lata Lima a legend yes
really absolutely she was a part of my
life a lot in those years so I I learned
a tremendous amount of her master
classes like with her different than
mine because I get into technical things
of how what it is to sing technically
and she never did that she never got
into technique at all it was all about
expression which was great you know
because we want that too I remember one
day I was singing I'll find a volunteer
a room of vogue evolved and it comes to
this great place where she blurts out
the singer anyway Oh mousse and she went
oh the audience stood up and cheered
it's really fun I've heard from from the
fellows that your master classes are are
pure gold because you don't all only
teach you you explain Ewing include
everybody in the room what was that
something that that the lata did or was
it or is that something you brought as
your special day sort of evolved now
because I've been doing classes for so
long and i happen to be a history buff
anyway and so I like the history of
things in music I love to know you know
what was sown so doing when Mark Twain
was writing that book or what was so in
so doing when vogner was writing that
you know so I I get a kick out of it
myself but I'm usually researching at
the last minute because I need some
dates you think Academy of the West is a
real team effort and you have the the
older generation helping and supporting
the younger generation of classical
musicians and you have this
amazing team does this yoga on offer
there's all sorts of thing it's at all
things that have been added recently
with our new president he's not new
anymore but scott reid is a truly
wonderful present and a lot of wonderful
you know innovations have started with
him you have sent out so many fellows
from music academy of the West out into
the Opera world do you watch them with
with pride justifying a career I
absolutely do it I just get real bright
that's all from Sarah's music for today
what a beautiful and inspiring place to
spend the whole summer surrounded by
music see you next time goodbye from
California so for today's horn challenge
who better to ask than Marilyn Horne
herself it's a huge honor there we go
you hold it there you put your hand in
here and in here is your singer lungs I
don't need to do anything here do
anything you just need to pucker up and
blow